المنتج نظرة
إذا كان شكله حلو وجميل ويلمع غالبًا الناس تقبله على طول
ولكن في تصنيفات دقيقة تعتمد على حسب نوع التمر
النخلة فيها «مفتّل» «جالكسي» و«رطب» و«قشر»
و«الجالكسي» أيش هو؟
المعارض اللي ما تقدر تشارك فيها، على الأقل زورها، أنت شخصيًّا
وشوف الناس، كيف تشارك؟
ناظر، مَن هُم الزبائن اللي يجون؟ وكيف يقدمون المنتجات حقتهم؟
وأيش المنتجات اللي قاعدين يقدمونها؟
ليش ما أصدر أنا مثلًا فاخر؟ أدري أنه ما راح يمشي أبد
لا سعرًا، ولا قبولًا عند الناس هناك برة
أنا وجدت هذا السوق
يقولون: هذا والله شكله؟
لا، لأن نسبة الألياف عالية
فغالبًا اللي ما يتعود على التمر، ما يقبله
بينما عندنا ال«مفتّل» هنا أغلى بكثير من الرطب
بس الرطب نسبة الماء فيه عالية، ونسبة الألياف فيه أقل، مقبول أكثر
حلو، تقدموا تمر خاص بـ«رونالدو» اسمه ألما؟
اسمه؟
الكلمة حقته دائمًا يقول: كالما
إي، يستاهل
بالما وكالما
إي يستاهل
أعطيكم أفكار تسويقية
بالعكس أبركها من ساعة نتشرف
يالله حيّهم، ضيفنا اليوم عبدالله الربدي
المؤسّس والرئيس التنفيذي لشركة «بالما» للتمور
أحد أكبر مصدّري التمور في السعودية
ومبيعاتهم السنة الماضية تُقدّر حوالي عشرات الملايين
في بداية الحلقة بنسولف على المنتج نفسه، التمر وأنواعه
وكيف ممكن تميّز بين التمر الجيّد من السيء سواءً كتاجر أو كعميل؟
ثم راح نغطي سلسلة الإمداد في سوق التمور عمومًا
ابتداءً من المزرعة وطريقة تعاملهم مع السوق، والتحديات اللي تواجههم
وطريقة عمل تُجار الجملة إلى ما يوصل التمر للمستهلك النهائي
ثم بنشوف
أيش الطريقة اللي اتبعوها «بالما» للتمور للتحكم في تكلفة المنتج؟
بعدها بنتكلم عن التصدير والأسواق الخارجية للتمر
وأيش الدول اللي تستورد من التمور؟
وكيف يقدر تاجر التمر أن يوصل للتُجّار والأسواق الخارجية؟
في حال رغب في التصدير
تفاصيل كثيرة راح نغطيها في هذه الحلقة
عن تجارة التمر عمومًا، وعن تصدير التمر خصوصًا، فأترككم معه
سعيد جدًّا بوجودك اليوم
أنا أسعد يا بعد عيني
وأنا سعيد جدًّا برضو أني أخيرًا استضفت واحد سوّى عمل تجاري
اللي كل سعودي يحلم أن يسويه
ممتاز
من كل خمس جلسات أجلس فيها مع ناس يسولفون بالأعمال التجارية
في جلسة واحدة، يجيك واحد أو اثنين يفكرون أنهم يصدرون تمر
ممتاز
أنهم يشوفون أن هذا المنتج متميزين فيه
والمفروض نصدره للعالم بأشكال مختلفة
حلو
فالحمد لله الحين صدنا واحد سوّاها
أبدًا، إن شاء الله، أقدم مادة حلوة
أنا سعيد جدًّا، أنه لقينا أحد يتكلم فيها، وتفاجأت
سابقًا، تذكر كان لنا جلسة نسولف في العمل التجاري هذا
لأن ما شاء الله، حجم التصدير عندكم كبير جدًّا
الحمد لله
أول شيء قبلما ندخل في كل التفاصيل هذه كلها
في سلسلة الإمداد والتسويق
وكل التفاصيل اللي لها علاقة في التجارة بالتمر
ودي أسولف عن التمر نفسه
حلو
الحين أنا قصمنجي، مثلما تعرف مثلك
دائمًا يوصلني التمر الزين
ممتاز، عندك واسطة أنت
بالضبط، كذا في العائلة دائمًا تلقى خال أو عم أو أي أحد
تلقى في واحد في العائلة أو اثنين أو ثلاثة أو أيًّا كان
إذا شفت بالمطبخ كراتين التمر، اعرف أن هذا موسم التمر
بالضبط، فما أدري إذا أنك شفت المقطع
اللي مصورين كذا حريم ينقون تمر
إلا أبد، هذه علامة الموسم
حاطين موسيقى «ناركوس» مسلسل حق مخدرات
هذه مخدراتنا
بالضبط، فدائمًا يوصل لك التمر الزين
فأنا بالنسبة لي ما قد وُضِعت في موقف أني أنقي تمر أو أشوفه
يجيك جاهز
يجيني جاهز وممتاز، ما أحتاج أني...
اللهم أني أعرف الشين، أيش هو؟
فشلون الواحد يميز بين التمر الزين والأقل جودة؟
كيف يشتري ويختار؟
بالضبط
بالنهاية التمر بشكل عام تحكمه بعض العوامل
لكن دائمًا يقولون بشكل عام بالتجارة، المنتج نظرة
إذا كان شكله حلو وجميل ويلمع غالبًا الناس تقبله على طول
ولكن في تصنيفات دقيقة تعتمد على حسب نوع التمر
فلو جينا مثلًا «للسكّري» يعتمد على عامل اللون
كلّما صار أصفر، صار أجمل
كلّما صار نسبة القشر فيه أقل، صار أغلى
كلّما صار حجم الحبة أكبر، صار تصنيفه فاخر ودرجة أولى وهكذا
فهي تعتمد على لون وحجم ونسبة قشرة، هذا إذا جينا مثلًا «للسكّري»
ولكن بشكل عام، التمر متى ما كان نظيف
ولون الصنف يرجع إلى اللون الحقيقي
فعلى سبيل المثال، إذا جينا قلنا: مثلًا «الصقعي» في أصفر وفي أحمر
ولكن الناس يفضلون دائمًا الأحمر، وعليه طوق أصفر
هذا يسمونه «مطوّق» يعتبر من أغلى التمور، وشكله حلو
ولكن تقارب المذاق واحد تقريبًا بالنسبة للتمور
فهذه هي التصنيفات الرئيسية
وأيش أنواع عادةً...
لما تيجي للتمور السمراء مثل «المجدول»
أتكلم كمبيعات
احنا بالنسبة لنا وبمنطقة القصيم يمكن «السكّري» يطغى
ثم يجي الخلاص، ولكن «السكّري» يعتبر الأعلى إنتاجًا
ومشهورة فيه المنطقة
تصنيفه، اللون كلما صار أصفر كلما صار أجمل
حجم حبة، ونسبة القشرة يكون، نسميها «مفتّل» أو «مفتول»
شارب قشرته
نسبة القشرة شلون؟
تصير حبة التمرة ما عليها قشرة مغطيتها، تكون القشرة منها وفيها
ما تحس أن إذا ضغطتها أن فيها...
ما تحس أن فيها قشرة تفكها، ثم تأكل التمر لحاله
لا، هي شاربة القشرة تُسمّى «مفتولة» أو «مفتّل»
حلو، متى بدأت العمل التجاري هذا؟
العمل كعمل تجاري تقريبًا ٢٠١٦
شلون العمل كعمل تجاري؟
أقصد كبيع وشراء، ولكن التمر...
في بداية غير العمل كعمل تجاري؟
لا، كان البداية يمكن هدايا، لكن دخولي بالمجال نفسه
كان عبارة عن ضيافات وهدايا، ما كان بيع وشراء
وتوصيات، بحكم أني على قولتك: من أهل المنطقة
والله أنت قصيمي، جيب لنا «السكّري» موجود عندكم
خاصةً فترة الابتعاث
أيش خلّاك تقول: خلاص أنا الحين ببيع؟
لما شفت فيه إقبال كبير جدًّا
وفيه استفهامات كبيرة في هذا المجال
واكتشفت أن كثير من الناس ما تفهم تفاصيل هذا المجال
ولا يعرف على قولتك: ما عمرك دخلت في حرج اختيار المنتج
يجيك جاهز وجودته ممتازة، ما عليك إلا تحطه في ثلاجتك
ولكن كثير من الناس ما يعرف شلون يختار، فيوصّي
التمر أنا بالنسبة لي مثل البخور والزعفران والعسل
اللي تحتاج إلى شخص ثقة يختار لك هذا المنتج
فوجدت أن فيه فراغ كبير ما بين معرفة المنتج والمشترين
فقلت: هذه فرصة
مع أن شرحك هذا يبيّن كأن الموضوع سهل، خلاص روح دوّر الحجم واللون
إي بالضبط، بالنسبة للمتمرّسين فيه يكون سهل
وما يبي له تعقيدات أنك تفهم المجال
سهل جدًّا إذا عرفت معايير التمر نفسه، وعرفت السوق أيش يبي؟
فعندنا احنا كل منطقة لها صنف معين
على سبيل المثال، «السكّري» نفسه فيه عدة أشكال
في «سكّري «مفتّل» و«سكري جالكسي» و«سكري رطب»
وفي «قشر يُضمد»
فله عدة أشكال، لكن «ال«مفتّل» مين يطلبه؟
«الجالكسي» مين يطلبه، والرطب مين يطلبه؟
أنا قلت: الموضوع سهل، عقّدته ليه الحين؟
لا، بس أنا أقصد أنك إذا فهمت هذه التفاصيل
وهي شيء بسيط مع الممارسة
بالعكس راح يكون لك تخصص جيّد فيه، ولك شريحة ممتازة
حلو، أنت بدأت مع أحد وللا بدأت لحالك؟
أنا بدأت كبيع وشراء مع تاجر تمر أخذ منه بالآجل، ما بدأت برأس مال
كنت أخذ منه بالآجل، أخذ منه عينات تمر
أعرضها على اللي حولي، ودائمًا تعرف العمل التجاري البدائي
اللي حولك هم أكبر الناس المشجعين لك
فيجاملونك في البدايات كمشتريات
فكنت أعرض عليهم العينات، وكنت حاط أقل شيء تطلب مثلًا أربعة كراتين
هذه 2017 صح؟
هذه 2016
ليش أعطاك التمر بالآجل؟
كنت أخذ منه بس عينات، ولا أطلّع منه الكمية إلا أنا مسدد له
فكنت أجي مثلًا لمشهور وأعرض له، أقول: أيش رأيك بالتمر، وجاز لك؟
أقول لك: هذا سعره كذا، وأقل طلبية تأخذ أربعة كراتين
فتجمع الفلوس...
فأجمع الفلوس، وأروح للرجل
وأقول له: طلّع لي هذه الكمية من الكراتين، وأوصّلها للناس
تأخذ عيّنة من كل نوع؟
لا، كنت مركز على نوع واحد، «سكّري «مفتّل» بدرجة معيّنة
حلو
وكنت متفق أنا وإيّاه على سعر بيع معيّن يبيعه علي
وأعرضه على الناس بسعر معين
ففرق السعر هذا الربح بالنسبة لي
ولحالك بدون استثمار ولا شيء؟
بدون أي شيء
وأيش الخطوة اللي بعدها كانت أجل؟
ثم بعدها، يوم شفت أن في إقبال
أنا زي ما قلت لك: المحيط اللي حولك المشترى الأول مجاملة
في منتج حساس مثل التمور، زي ما ذكرنا أنه مشابه للبخور والعسل وغيره
إذا رجع لك الزبون إذن هنا مؤشر جيّد بالنسبة لك، إذن اختيارك جيّد
وشفت أنه عملائي اللي حولي...
قصدك بعدما تخلص مرحلة المجاملات؟
بالضبط، بعدما تخلص مرحلة المجاملات يجي الجد هنا، ما في
فلوس هذه، عرفت كيف
فالآن في رجوع جيّد وممتاز
فوجدت أن لا، الموضوع يستاهل، وفيه طلب جيّد
والسوق فيه حجم ما هو بسيط
وراح نجي لحجم السوق السعودي
قد يكون مؤشر لأي أحد يبي يدخل بهذا القطاع، يشجعه أنه يدخل
فلما شفت أنه لا، أنا قاعد أتمكن من هذه الصنعة
وقاعد أفهمها بشكل سريع، وأعرف الزبائن، أيش هم يبون؟
والسعر اللي أنا أعرضه مقابل الجودة، ممتاز
إذن خلني أكبّر الدائرة، بدال ما هي بس بمنطقتي
وأنا قاعد أبيعها على البيوت اللي حولي من عمات وخالات وعموم وهكذا
لا راح أكبر شوي
فالحمد لله، توسّع الموضوع بطريقة جيدة
وكانت طريقة المشترى الأول
زي ما قلت لك: التاجر يعطيني إياه وبالآجل
أنه عيّنات، وأنا أعطيه المبالغ وأبيعه
عقبًا، دخلت في سالفة أشتري، تجرأت شوي على الشراء
أشتري، وأخزّن شيء بسيط، وأبيعه
وين كنت تخزّن، وين منطقة التخزين؟
كنت أشتري مساحات بالطبلية هي طبعًا
نظام تخزين التمور عبارة عن ثلاجات، غُرف فيها طبالي
لها معايير معيّنة
الطبلية تأخذها مثلًا خلنا نقول: مجمّد بالشهر تكلفك 90 ريال
تشيل 260 كرتون
بدأتها بزي كذا، أخذ طبلية، وأحط فيها تمري
وأسدد إيجارها الشهري، لكن ما تسوى إلى التمر
إذا 90 ريال تشيل 260 كرتون، تعتبر ممتازة بالنسبة لي
متوسط من 80 إلى 120 ريال
80 إلى 120 ريال للطبلية؟
للطبلية إيوة، وتخزّن فيها، تأخذ طبليتين أو ثلاثة أو أربعة، شهرية هذه
حلو
إيوة، ما يحتاج أنك تروح تأخذ غرفة كاملة
وكم كان يقعد معك مخزّن؟
كنت أنا طبعًا أخذ بالموسم، وأبيع خلال الموسم وفترة الشتاء
كم مدة الموسم؟
الموسم بالأشهر الميلادية
«الخَرَاف» في أغسطس بالنسبة لمنطقة القصيم «السكّري»
«الخَرَاف» أيش هو؟
«الخَرَاف» اللي هو قطف التمر من النخل
معلش، تحمّلني
كمصطلح صحيح، يُسمّى خَرَاف، اللي هو قطف التمر من النخل
هذا أي شهر؟
في أغسطس، شهر ثمانية ميلادي
ويستمر إلى نهاية أغسطس، وبداية تسعة
تبدأ دخول التمور الأخرى، على سبيل المثال «الصقعي» و«المجدول»
ثم نبدأ الخلاص تدريجيًّا، وهكذا إلى تقريبًا بدايات أكتوبر
هذا الموسم اللي هو موسم ما بين يُسمّى «خَرَاف» و«صرام» أو «جداد»
كم، ثلاثة شهور تقريبًا؟
تقريبًا شهرين وشوي
السنة هذه احنا تأخر معنا الموسم بناءً على الأجواء
ف«الخَرَاف» تأخر
أجل أنت الوحيد اللي ينبسط إذا جاء أغسطس؟
والله أنا أنبسط مع الحر، إلى أن على قولتهم نخلّص...
بالضبط، ونعبّي مخازننا، وأمورنا تمام، احنا مبسوطين
فبعد هذا يُعتبر موسم اللي هو زي ما قلنا «الخَرَاف»
أو قطف التمر من النخل، ثم يجيك مواسم
اللي هي مواسم بيعية، اللي هو موسم الموسم نفسه
ثم موسم الشتاء، الناس تحب الضميد أو ما يُسمّونه «بالمكنوز»
سواءً اليدوي أو مسحوب الهواء المصنعي
اللي هو غالبًا في الشتاء يفُضّل بالبرد
ثم الموسم الكبير، اللي هو موسم رمضان
فهذه هي المواسم بالنسبة للتمر
رمضان له شيء خاص وللا؟
لا، ترجع الدائرة، هي كذا قوس
وقت الموسم الناس يحبون تمر الثلاجة
ممتاز، اللي هو «سكّري «مفتّل» و«الجالكسي» أيًّا كان
الشتاء يفضلون التمور المضمودة، سواءً يدوية أو مصنعية
وقت البرد والطلعات والكشتات
أيش فرق التمر المضمودة عن التمور...؟
يكون مكنوز ومضمود، اللي يُسمّى «جَروِش ومجَروِش» مثلًا
و«ضميد» يُسمّى أو «مكنوز» حسب...
تجيك مضغوطة مع بعض كذا؟
بالضبط، يكون التمر مضغوط
والضغط نوعين، إما يدوي يُسمّى شعبي أو مسحوب الهواء
اللي هو آلة سحب الهواء المصنعي
ثم لا قرّب رمضان يرجعون لحق الثلاجة، اللي هو «مفتّل» و«جالكسي» وكذا
معناته أنت تخزّن من أغسطس، أو خلينا نقول من أكتوبر
نهاية الموسم إلى رمضان؟
فيه تمور نعم، احنا تخزيننا يعتمد على الصنف
فعندنا على سبيل المثال، تمور التصدير
احنا مخصصين بـ«السكّري» تحديدًا الرطب
عندنا أكثر من درجة بالنسبة للرطب، هذا نصدره
ونبدأ بيعنا في الموسم، في أغسطس وسبتمبر
وقت خَرَافنا وكذا، هذا عقود عندنا...
نجي على التصدير، بس التخزين محليًا هنا؟
إي، أنا أقصد هذا صنف، هذا ما راح نخزّنه لرمضان
هذا نبدأ بيعه...
شيء خاص للتصدير يكون؟
إي، هذا شيء خاص للتصدير
راح أجيك بعدين ليش؟
إي، وشيء خاص على قولتهم، ندخّله في موسم الضمد
نضمده عشان نجهزه للشتاء، وهذا يُخزّن للشتاء
وشيء خاص لرمضان...
هو نفسه «السكّري» هو اللي يُضمّد؟
إي هو نفسه السكري، بس درجات
زي ما قلت لك: في «السكّري الناشف» هذا للضميد
و«السكّري» الليّن أو اللي يُسمّى «مفتّل» هذا للثلاجة، يُباع كما هو بشكله
وليش يُضمّد التمر؟
هذا اللي يصير ناشف وقاسية التمرة، فيُضمد ويطلع...
أنها تكون غير صالحة للاستهلاك
لا، تصير قاسية أنك تأكلها كما هي
فتُضمد بأكياس تطلع لنا مقرمشة
تحوّلها إلى منتج الثاني
إي، تحوّلها إلى شكل يُسمّى «مكنوز»
يطلع الشكل أجمل، وله رغبته في الشتاء
أنا قاعد أراعي أنه في ناس يتابعون الحلقة، وما عندهم أي فكرة
لا، احنا بنفصفصها بس شوي شوي
فقاعد أضبطها
في الشتاء ليش تعتقد هذا يمشي لأكثر من...؟
«السكّري» تحديدًا، الضميد يُفضل بالبرد؛ لأنه حار شوية
على الكبد
إي، فيفضلونه بالشتاء مع الطلعات وكذا
التمور بشكل عام المجروشة يفضلونها بالشتاء
سواءً كانت «خلاص»...
مجروشة يجيك عليها زي السكر؟
اللي هو، بالضبط، تحويل اللي هو دبس التمر
الحين التمر لما ينضغط، يطلع دبس
ثم مع تغيّرات البرودة والحرارة يتحول هذا الدبس السائل
إلى بلّورات أو سكّريات متعددة تُسمّى «جروشة»
فتلقى مثلًا جروشة الخلاص قريبة للطحين
«جروشة السكّري» قريبة للسكر، كأنها حبيبات سكر، فهذا معنى «الجروشة»
حلو، ورمضان ما قلت لي، أيش التمر اللي تبيعونه؟
الثلاجة نفسه، اللي كان وقت الموسم، اللي هو حق الثلاجة
ما هو مضمود، يفضلونه الناس اللي هو...
وكم ممكن يقعد معك في الثلاجة ويعطيك...؟
التمر ما له عمر صراحةً بشكل عام
إذا أنت خزّنته تخزين جيد، يعيش معك سنوات
وبنفس الجودة وبدون ما؟
إي، خاصةً إذا كان تجميده في ثلاجات زي ما كانوا أهلنا يسوون
ثلاجة تمر وما يُلمَس هذا، وما يُفتح، وما يدخل له لحم
ولا يدخل له منتجات أخرى
فأنت تخزّن جزء من تمر الموسم لرمضان؟
بالضبط
التفاصيل اللي الآن ذكرناها، أنا متأكد في نسبة من المستمعين الآن
قد تكون كبيرة ضاعوا، ما يدرون الحين أيش تتكلم عنه
فأنت فاهم بالتفاصيل هذه، يمكن أنا فاهم في بعض التفاصيل هذه
ما بقول أني فاهم في نفس اللي أنت فاهم فيه
بس العميل الآن إذا جاء بيختار التمر، هو أساسًا ما يعرف أيش المعايير
هذا كيف تقدر تميّز نفسك في هذه الحالة بين التُجّار؟
أبسط طريقة، زي ما قلنا، إذا مثلًا نتكلم عن «السكّري» تحديدًا
هو اللي فيه شائك التمر هذا، لونه أصفر أو يميل للصفار
نسبة القشر فيه منخفضة، ما عليه قشرة
هذا واضح، أنا قصدي العميل في السوق اللي ما سمع هذا الكلام
داخل المحل وللا راح لموقع وللا أيًّا كان التاجر اللي يشتري منه
وشاف عنده «تمر سكّري»
شلون يعرف هذا زين، وشلون تميّز نفسك أنت؟
هذا اللي أنا أقوله: أن الزبون لما يجي ويشوف التمر
كيف يقول: هذا كويس وللا لا؟
بس ما يعرف المعايير
المعايير هذه لون...
لا، هذه المعايير الواضحة
بس قصدي العميل اللي ما يعرف المعايير
أيش اللي يخليه يميز بين التفاصيل؟
يعني أنا واحد ما عندي معايير نهائيًّا، أنا أمريكي جاي الحين
وبشتري تمر، أيش اللي يخليه يقدر يميّز بين التمر؟
غالبًا، الناس اللي ما يعرفون التمر، يذوق
يقول: والله مذاقه كويس، ويقبله خلاص
والناس مذاقات
حلو
في ناس ما يهمهم حجم الحبة قد ما هي نظيفة
في ناس ما يهمه أن فيها قشرة بس إنها كبيرة
حسب، الناس أذواق شوي، فتختلف أذواقهم في اختيار التمر
وتعتقد أن الناس اللي ما يعرفون المعايير يميزون بين الجودة؟
ممكن، شوف أنت بتقول: أنا لو كنت أجنبي مثلًا أمريكي
غالبًا الأجانب مذاق، بيذوق، والله مذاقه جيّد، إذن جاز لي
لأن هم عكسنا يمكن، وعكس القصمان تحديدًا
ما عنده مرجع للطعم
بالضبط، بس يظل عنده ذائقة
تمر حق الفنادق هذا اللي أنا أكرهه
بس يظل فيه ذائقة، أنه والله مقبول وللا لا
هذه الذائقة هي بالنسبة له عبارة عن أداة تقييم، أنه يقبل أو ما يقبل
لكن أنت تتكلم عن احنا في مجتمعنا مثلًا
اللي يشوف التمر، هذه المعايير الأساسية
اللي تقدر تقول: والله هذا جيّد وللا لا، وهي تبدأ من نظافة التمر
بس التفاصيل هذه، ما تتوقع أنها تخلي العملاء اللي يشترون منك بشكل أساسي
هم العملاء اللي فاهمين بالتمر أكثر؟
لا بالعكس، احنا اليوم دورنا أو الناس اللي مثلنا من حقين التمور المختصين
قاعدين يقدمون صراحة منتجات جدًّا ممتازة
يتعبون على تنظيفه وفرزه وتدريجه
بحيث أنه يقدمه للزبون اللي يعرف واللي ما يعرف
أنه يجيه منتج جيّد وذو جودة وسعر مناسب
فكيف تسوّق له؟
كيف أنت تسوق لها؟
كيف تسوق للتمور تحديدًا؟
وكيف توصّل للعميل العادي، اللي مو زيك
أنه هذا التمر ممتاز، وأفضل من التمر اللي عند غيري؟
أنت ما لك إلا تشرح التمر، وتقدم معلومة مجانية
في نهاية المطاف، صاحب القرار هو العميل اللي بيدفع
فأنت تتكلم عنه بخبرتك والمعلومات اللي تراها إضافية
للعميل اللي ما يعرف، وهو بناءً على ما يسمع ويتلقى، ويتخذ القرار
ثم عاد تجي على قولتهم
الاختبار الحقيقي هو التجربة اللي لما يوصل لهم بالبيت
هل هو كما أنت ذكرته ووصفته أو مختلف عن الوصف؟
فتصير أنت معتمد مثلًا على التثقيف من خلال المشاهير؟
بالضبط، هذا جزء كبير ومهم
أذكر في أحد الحملات التسويقية
سوينا حملة كاملة نعلّم الناس أيش يعني جروشة
نحول سائل دبس التمر إلى بلّورات
لأنه كان فيه سؤال كثير
هل فعلاً هذه جروشة حقيقية من التمر، وللا تضيفون له سكر؟
في ناس يضيفون له سكر؟
ما في أحد يضيف له سكر
لأنه شكله كأنه سكر؟
شكله كأنه، حتى لو غسلته يمكن يطلع معك أبيض، الشكل حق...
هذا جروشة «السكّري»
فالحملات التسويقية تخليها على شكل محتوى تثقيفي؟
بالضبط، هذا جزء منها، أنك تثقف الناس، تقدّم لهم معلومة
الجزء البيعي
اللي هو التغليف والهدية والتفاصيل هذه الثانية اللي تساعدك في البيع
الخدمات الموجودة عندك، سرعة التوصيل والتبريد والسعر المنافس وهكذا
هذه بيعية مباشرة، وهذيك تثقيفية، ولكن هي مكملة لبعض
التسعير كيف تقرر؟
التسعير تقريبًا السوق متقارب، اليوم المنتج هو سعر مكشوف
ما هو مستورد، فهو تمر في نهاية المطاف
أنت تعطي الزبون غالبًا البيوت هو الدرجة المتوسطة
ما تبي أنت اللي غالي جدًّا اللي هو يُؤخذ هدايا أو يُسمّى نوادر بالسوق
ولا اللي هو درجات أقل، ما تُقبل فيه الاستهلاك المادي
فأنت فعليًّا إذا جيت، خلنا نقول: تبيع منتج للزبون
أنت تستهدف المنتج اللي يوازن ما بين الجودة والسعر
بالضبط
ما تبي تجيب الشيء تقول: أنا مقدم أفضل منتج في السوق؟
هذا الكلام
وتحصر نفسك على...
أن تضيف خيار موجود أعلى جودة للناس اللي يبونه
لكن ما هي الخيار الأول، أنت تقدمه له كخيار
في ناس يقول له: أنا أبي هدية فاخرة مرة، وعندي استعداد أدفع الرقم اللي تبون
فهذا يعطيك مساحة أنك تبني منتجات مختلفة
بالضبط، ولكن المعيار بناءً على تحليلنا من بدأنا إلى اليوم
في كل سنة أو في كل موسم نجي نبدأ نبيع فيه
خلاص هذا المطلوب، السوق يبي كذا والبيوت تبي هذا المنتج
فأنت تقدم له المنتج اللي يحتاجه
ليش تروح تقدم له منتج غالي جدًّا؟
وهو منتج استهلاكي في نهاية المطاف
وأتصور يبيّن مع حجم الطلب من خلال التسعير، الأسعار المختلفة؟
بالضبط، واشرح أيضًا، درجة أولى أو فاخر أو نوادر تمر وهكذا
كرتون التمر اللي تقول عنه كم سعره، وكم سعر كرتون التمر اللي يأخذونه هدايا؟
مثلًا، المقياس الثلاثة كيلو، إذا قلت مثلًا
كراتين بـ 50-80 ريال، هذه تعتبر أسعار ممتازة
في كراتين تصل إلى 150-200 ريال
وفي كراتين تصل إلى 300 أو 350 ريال
بالنسبة لي، ما هو من المنطق أن يكون هذا الاستهلاك اليومي للبيت
بـ 80 ريال يعتبر ممتاز، لونه ومذاقه جيّد، والتمرة نظيفة
إذن هذا للاستهلاك العالي
هذاك قد يكون تصنيف هدايا أو تقديمات أو ضيافة أو أشياء أخرى
ولكن ما هو للاستهلاك اليومي
الاستهلاك اليوم المفروض يكون شيء رخيص عشان...؟
بالضبط، والهوامش عادةً كم تكون في...؟
التمور، تُعتبر زي الهوامش الغذائية، تقريبًا متوسط 30%
على مستوى المنتج من غير التكاليف طبعًا؟
على مستوى المنتج نعم
ودّي أخذك أكثر على سلسلة الإمداد الحين
بدايتها من المزارع، أنتم تتعاملون أتصور الحين مع مزارع مباشرة صحيح؟
إي، عندنا عدة نقاط توريد، ومزارع مُلكية خاصة، ومزارع إيجار طويل
بس نأخذها كسلسلة إمداد الآن
عندك أنت أول شيء المزارع
حلو
عندك بعدين، مين اللي يأخذ من المزارع؟
عندك المزارع، والخيارات وقت الموسم
عندك المزارع اللي تابعة لك
وعندك اللي هو السوق نفسه اللي أنت تشتري منه التمور
فبالنسبة لمخازننا، مصدر التمور...
فهي من المزارع مباشرة تروح للسوق؟
إي، أنا بجيك الآن
بالنسبة لمصادر التمر اللي يدخل على ثلاجاتنا أو مخازننا
تجي من مزارعنا
لا، خلّي الحين من وين تأخذون التمر
أتكلم بالسوق بشكل عام، سلسلة الإمداد في التمر
التمرة لما تُخرَف من النخلة تمر على مراحل الفرز والتدريج
«السكّري»، على سبيل المثال، احنا نتكلم عنه عشان تكون الصورة واضحة
النخلة فيها «مفتّل» وفيها «جالكسي» ورطب وقشر
الجالكسي أيش هو؟
«الجالكسي» هو التمر اللي ما بين الرطبة وال«مفتّل»ة الناشفة
تكون لونها قريب للحَمَار
وما هي بليّنة مرة، ولكن ما هي قاسية، تُسمّى «جالكسي» في تصنيف التمر
حلو
فغالبًا «الخَرَاف»ين يحطون التمر هذا بسطل، والسطل يروح لمستودع الفرز
ثم يُصنّف، يطلع ال«مفتّل» لحال و«السكّري ال«مفتّل»
والرطب لحال و«الجالكسي» لحال
ثم كل صنف له عدة درجات، هذا الفاخر منه، وهذا الدرجة الأولى
وهذا الدرجة الثانية
هذه الدرجات متعارف عليها عند المزارعين؟
شلون؟
الدرجات هذه متفقين عليها المزارعين؟
هذه معروفة، معيار معروف، ثم تُوَرّد للسوق حسب الصندوق
اللي هي أيش، معلش المعيار؟
اللي هو إذا فصل، بالنسبة «للسكّري ال«مفتّل» لحال ثم الرطب ثم «الجالكسي»
الدرجات قصدي أيش هي؟
ثم الدرجات، كل مزرعة حسب إنتاجها
فهذه مثلًا فاخر، وهذا درجة أولى، وهذا درجة ثانية
حسب تصنيفك داخل المزرعة
أعلى شيء أيش هو؟
الفواخر أو تُسمّى اللي أعلى شيء، وهو كمية قليلة جدًّا
اللي يُسمّى «نوادر تمر» اللي يجي حبات كبيرة
ولكن المزرعة تلقى تطلع فيها 3-4 كيلوّات
فقط تمر نادر، تمر فاخر، درجة أولى، درجة ثانية
ثم تُورّد للسوق
عشان يحرّج عليها، هذه تُورّد حسب الصنف
مستحيل يبيعك سيارة بها صنفين «مفتّل» و«جالكسي» جميع
ما زاد «مفتّل» لحال، يزودون عليه
ثم يسوون مزاد على مثلًا «الجالكسي» أو الرطب أو غيرها
والمزارعين كلهم يروحون لمزادات؟
والمزارعين يجون للمزادات
وبعض المزارعين ماسك خط توريد مثلًا، عقود مع تُجّار معينين بايع لهم
حلو
إي، نعم
والمزادات هذه مَن يحضرها؟
المزادات هذه يحضرها الفرد، سواءً أصحاب البيوت اللي يجي يشتري لبيته
أو التُجّار المزارعين أو الناس اللي من برة
سواءً خليجيين أو عرب أو مَن يتاجر في التمر
إذا بروح لواحد في القصيم، وين تكون المزادات عادةً؟
في أسواق، بريدة وعنيزة فيهم سوق مركزي
البكيرية فيها سوق مركزي
في أسواق مركزية تُسمّى سوق التمر
الفترات اللي يجي فيها الناس؟
غالبًا بالنسبة للسوق من بعد صلاة الفجر مباشرة
قصدي الأيام؟
هو وقت الموسم، وقت الخراف اللي هو من أغسطس
كامل وقت الموسم؟
إي، لأن المزارعين يخرّفون، ويودون للسوق
اللي هو غالبًا من أغسطس إلى تقريبًا...
يوميًا موجودين من الفجر؟
يوميًا من بعد صلاة الفجر إلى تقريبًا سبعة أو سبعة ونص
يكون، ما شاء الله، السيارات كلها تم بيعها
ثم الفترة المسائية اللي هي من بعد صلاة العصر
حلو، بعدين أتصور في تُجّار الجملة يجون يشتروهم؟
بالضبط، تجّار الجملة والأفراد، والناس اللي من برة ويصدرون يجون يشترون
السوق مفتوح للجميع
حلو، مين اللي من برة يجون يصدّرون؟
سواءً الخليجيين أو الأجانب أيًّا كان، الناس اللي لهم توريد
وبعدين يجون تجّار التجزئة يشترون من تُجّار الجملة ويبيعوا؟
بالضبط
ما في وسطاء في أي مرحلة من المراحل؟
طبعًا المزارع ودلّال وتاجر
الدلّال هذا أيش يصير؟
الدلّال اللي هو يدلل على السيارات، يحرّج عليهم
المزارع يكون مثلًا موقّع مع مشهور كدلّال
يورّد سيارات وتمر له، ومشهور مسؤول عن التحريج على هذه السيارات وبيعها
وأيش الاتفاق اللي يصير بينهم؟
يكون أنا أورّد لك تمري، والدلّال يأخذ نسبة متعارف عليها بالسوق
10% من مبيعات المزارع
بحيث أنه يضمن للمزارع بيعها والاستلام والتسليم بينه وبين التاجر
فهو لتاجر الجملة يأخذها فرق
خلنا نقول: عن سعر البيع النهائي بـ 20% مثلًا؟
لا، هو في نهاية المطاف التاجر ما يأخذ
خلاص يأخذها ويوقّف الكرتون هذا بـ 50 ريال، والتاجر يأخذها بـ 50 ريال
الدلّال يتفاهم مع المزارع، يأخذ مثلًا 10% من الـ 50 ريال
أقصد، خلينا نقول: الكرتون يُباع بـ...
المشكلة أنه ما أبي أدخل في النسب، نحوس الدنيا شوي
الحين الدلّال يأخذ 10% من قيمة البيع اللي تصير في المزارع
بالضبط
تاجر الجملة بيضيف عليها نسبة، وبعدين تاجر التجزئة بيضيف عليها
إي، بس الـ 10% الدلّال يأخذها من المزارع ما يأخذها من التاجر أساسًا
إي، حلو هو بيأخذها من سعر البيع للتاجر
إي خلاص
ما رح يضيفه علي
تم وقف الحراج خلنا نقول: بـ 60 ريال
التاجر أخذها بـ 60 ريال، وراح
وأيش النسبة اللي يتكسب منها التاجر؟
كل تاجر وطريقته
تُجّار الجملة إذا باعوا لتُجّار التجزئة، كم يطلعون تقريبًا نسبة وهامش ربح؟
يعتمد، هذه متفاوتة مثل أي سلعة أخرى
تقريبًا؟
كلّن له أسلوبه، بعضهم يعتمد على هوى اليوم
يبيع كميات ضخمة جدًّا، وبهوامش بسيطة جدًّا
فيركز على المبيعات العالية
وبعضهم لا، كميات بسيطة، ولكن تربح خلال الموسم
فيحط ربحه الجيّد فيه، ولا يهمه أن الزبون هذا يشتري أو لا
يقول: أنا هذا سعري، تبي تأخذ فيه وللا خلّه
والتاجر النهائي اللي هو تاجر التجزئة يطلّع 30-40% تقريبًا
إي، ولكن هي أسواق مختلفة، وأصناف التمور مختلفة
في بعض التمور تقدر تأخذها، إذا أنت تاجر جيّد، ومشترياتك جيدة
تشتري جودة المنتجات، منتج جيّد بأسعار منخفضة
فتقدر تأخذ فيها ربحية عالية، ولكن احنا أي شيء نذكره هو متوسط
حلو، هذه سلسلة الإمداد الاعتيادية، أنتم أيش تسوون مختلف؟
احنا نفس الشيء، عندنا احنا بالنسبة لمخازننا، يجينا تمر مباشر من مزارعنا
أيش سالفة المزارع هذه حقتكم؟
المزارع حقنا، هذه تبع الشركة تكون مزارع
أيش خلّاكم تقول: أنا بروح أسوي مزارع بدال ما تروح تتعامل مع المزارعين؟
احنا المزارع بالنسبة لنا على عدة أشكال
في مزارع مُلْكية، وفي مزارع عقود بيننا وبين المزارعين تكون طويلة
وفي مزارع نشتري الثمر جاهز، ويدخل مباشرة إلى ثلاجاتنا
وفي وقت «الخَرَاف» اللي من مزارعنا ومخصصينه لثلاجاتنا، يدخل مباشرة
في شيء من مزارعنا نبيعه بالسوق
ليش؟
نفضل أنه نبيعه بالسوق، خاصةً الأشياء الفواخر
نفضل أنه نكيّشهن على طول وقت السوق والمزاد
لتوفير سيولة وللا؟
إي، وبنفس الوقت هذول فواخر، قيمتهن عالية
فحرام أن يمسكن عليك مبالغ داخل مخازن، بها مخاطرة
أنت مركّز للعملاء اللي تبيعهم بالدرجة الأولى؟
أنا عندي النوادر والفواخر والدرجة الأولى، والدرجات حقت التصدير
بس أنت تقول: الفواخر الحين تحاول تصرّفها بسرعة
النوادر
قلت: الفواخر قبل شوي
والفواخر قد نضيف منها جزء، وجزء نضيفها عندنا في المخازن
طبعًا هي ما هي كتاب مسجل، هي تعتمد على السوق
إذا السوق عزيز ما تبيع ولا شيء
السوق السنة هذه مثلًا عزيز ما تدخّل أي شيء، بيع وسيولة حاضرة
وأيش السوق العزيز؟
أسعاره كويسة بالنسبة للمزارع
فيه متوسط سعر الكرتون بالنسبة للمزارع مُجدي
فخلاص ورّد مباشرة
لا شفت السوق بالنسبة لنا، احنا استراتيجيتنا
والله السوق أسعاره ما هي جيدة لنا كمزارعين
لا، نخزّنه عندنا شهرين أو ثلاثة أو أربعة، إلى أن خلاص ما في سوق
فتبيعه بسعر مُجدي بالنسبة لك
أيش اللي يؤثر في الأسعار في السوق؟
تأثيرات السوق مثله مثل أي...
عرض وطلب؟
عرض وطلب، هذا أهم شيء، ثم أشياء أخرى
فأنت كأنك تقول: بمسك التمر إلى أن ما يتوازن العرض والطلب
بالضبط، اللي هو تخزّنه للموسم، اللي هو رمضان على سبيل المثال
فتبيعه بوقت يكون يمكن فيه العرض أقل
فيه طلب عالي بالضبط
إي، بس أنت ما جاوبت على السؤال اللي سألتك إيّاه في البداية
اللي هو، ليش أساسًا صار عندكم مزارع خاصة فيكم؟
طبعًا هنا لعدة أمور
واحد منها، ضبط جودة المنتج اللي يدخل عندنا في الثلاجات
فمزرعتي واهتمامي فيها أضمن المنتج أن يكون جيّد
زائد، ضبط متوسط سعر التكلفة الموجود عندي
زائد أن وفرة المنتج، أن يكون عندي
فهي ثلاثة عوامل رئيسية، عند أي تاجر، وفرة وجودة وسعر
ما تحس تشتتك أنك تصير تدير مزارع بالإضافة لأنك تبيع التمر؟
أبدًا، بالعكس إذا كان حجم الشغل الموجود عندك كبير
فهو يستحق، أنك تشتغل على المزارع والسوق
بس واضح أنك طحت في مشاكل مع المزارعين سابقًا
وهذا شيء طبيعي
هي اللي خلتك تقول: بسوي مزرعة
لكن في نهاية المطاف أنت كلما كبر سوقك
إلا ما تروح تقص تكاليف، وترفع جودة
وتوفر كمية على العقود اللي أنت مرتبط بها
أيش المشاكل اللي طحت فيها مع الطريقة التقليدية؟
طبعًا من أكبر المشاكل بالنسبة لتُجّار التمر، على سبيل المثال
أنه لما يجي مثلًا تمر مختلف، الفرزة ما هي اللي هو يبيها
فهو شاري على أنها درجة معينة فتجيه شوي درجة مختلفة
أني مثلًا متفق مع مشهور في مزرعته، أن أنا بورّد الكمية الفلانية
وأنا مرتبط أساسًا من هناك في عقد مباشر لتوريد لجهة معينة
ومشهور ما يورّد لي الاتفاق المتفق عليه، فهذه بالنسبة للكمية
بس هذه مو يتأثر بسبب عوامل طبيعية يمرون فيها المزارعين؟
هذا جزء منها، وجزء منها أنه عدم التزام في العقود
يكون والله جاءه وبيعة زينة، فمثلًا ما التزم بالعقد
زائد التغييرات السعرية، أنت عشان تضبطها
لما تكون من مزارعك، فأنت ضابط وعارف تكاليفك الداخلة عليك
من يد عاملة وأسمدة وتشغيل وغيره
فتعرف كم متوسط التكلفة الموجودة عندك بالنسبة لك
زي ما قلت لك: إذا كان حجمك كبير فهذا يخارج معك، لأنك تسوي عليه ضبط
التكاليف في المزارع الثانية تختلف من سنة لسنة؟
الطبيعي، في بعض المزارعين ما يعرف يضبط تكاليفه
فيبيع مثلًا بسعر عالي
سنة يبيع لك أغلى وسنة أرخص
بالضبط، لكن أنت زي ما قلت لك: هو يعتمد
وهي استراتيجيات، وهي ليست كتاب مكتوب
احنا وجدنا أن هذه الاستراتيجية تتناسب مع الشركة حقتنا
والتوجّه اللي احنا رايحين له
أذكر قلت لي سابقًا عن موضوع توفر العمالة للمزارع برضو يأثر على...
هذا جزء منها، واجهنا مثلًا في كورونا مشاكل كثيرة
ما كان في عدد عمالة كافي، فهذا أثّر على السوق بشكل كبير
أيش علاقته بالعقار؟ أذكر كان فيه علاقة بالتطور العقاري
هذه كانت مثلًا، أعلق وأقول: إذا هدّى العقار، تلقى عمالة المزارع تزود
لأن تصير فيه هجرة بين عمالة المقاولين للزراعيين، والعكس صحيح
حلو، فمستفيد
إي فهذه عارضة على قولتهم
بس فعلًا يصير هذا الشيء وللا؟
والله يصير
هذا ممكن يأثر على التكاليف، مثلًا لو دعس العقار
لا دعس العقار وسحب العمالة كلهم هناك
ترتفع تكاليف العمالة الباقيين
يصير فيه شُح في الأيادي العاملة، فترتفع عليك تكلفة يومية العامل اليومية
أو شركة المقاولات اللي أنت موقع معها الزراعية
حلو، فأنتم عندكم مزارعكم الآن الخاصة
طبعًا الأشياء العوامل الجوية والأمور الثانية خارجة عن سيطرتكم
هذه أيش اللي عادةً تكون ممكن يدمر لكم المحصول؟
على سبيل المثال، لما يجي في الموسم رطوبة أو مطر
يأثر على جودة المنتج
ما يجيه حر كافي، فالتمر ما يجيك كامل
أنت حاط حساباتك أن هذه المزرعة متوسط النخلة
يطلّع لك 90 أو 100 أو 120 كيلو
والله ما أعطيتك إلا 50 كيلو، إذن هذه على المزارع تعتبر خسارة
لأن جزء كبير من التمر ما جاء
فهذه من ضمن العوامل اللي تؤثر على المزارعين
هذه تحوسك في التكاليف؟
طبيعي
بس أيش تسوي، الحين طار نص محصولك؟
الشكوى لله
ترجع المزارع ثاني مرة
خلص
المشكلة حتى المزارع تأثرت في...
إي، على سبيل المثال الموسم الماضي جتنا الرطوبة تقريبًا 3 أيام
بالنسبة للسكّري في بعض المزارع صار أحمر وقشّر
هذا مثلًا الكرتون اللي بـ 50 أو 60، صار مثلًا بـ 20 أو 25 أو 30 ريال
بحكم أنه لونه صار أحمر، وصار فيه نسبة قشر
فهذا أيضًا أثّر على جودة المنتج
المزارع كلها أتصور منطقة واحدة؟
لا، المزارع متنوعة، ولكن بعض المناطق تتأثر
وين تكون أماكنها؟
احنا بالنسبة لنا، في مزارعنا احنا نستهدف
بالنسبة للقصيم بريدة تحديدًا، نستهدف شمال غرب
بحكم إننا نشتغل على «السكّري»، فهذه من ضمن الأراضي الممتازة
بس أقصد كل مزارعكم هناك؟
احنا بالنسبة لنا كل مزارعنا هناك، عندهم تركيز هناك
أي عوامل جوية تجي فهي بتأثر على كل مزارعكم؟
تقريبًا
المزارع الثانية وين؟
احنا بالنسبة لنا؟
لا أقصد المزارعين الثانيين
كلّن ومزرعته
سواءً نتكلم عن منطقة القصيم في كل مكان، ما شاء الله
كلها أراضي زراعية
فإذا صار في شيء في منطقتكم، ممكن منطقة ثانية
قد يكون منطقة ثانية ما فيها شيء
فتروحون تأخذون تمر من هناك؟
هنا يجي العرض والطلب اللي احنا كنا نتكلم عنه
لما تصير الجودة تقل هنا، وتصير الجودة الطيبة شوية، ترتفع سعرها
فهذه من ضمن العوامل اللي تؤثر
وفي برامج حكومية لدعمكم من ناحية زراعة التمر؟
طبعًا، في وزارة الزراعة، وبرامج التمويل من ضمن صادرات السعودية
هذه برامج كلها حكومية وتقدّم
الصادرات بنجيها، بس الزراعة نفسها في أي شي يدعم؟
في برامج زراعية وبرامج الأسمدة، وبرامج اليد العاملة
هذه كلها برامج موجودة حكومية، وتدعم هذه القطاعات
أعطيني فكرة عن كل واحد من البرامج
مثلًا مشتريات الأسمدة
في الجمعيات الزراعية أيضًا تقدم لك هذه المشتريات مثلًا الكرتون
تقدم لك إياه، بس تقدم لك الخدمة؟
تسهيلات الشراء
زي أيش؟
مثلًا جدولة الدفعات، توفر لك المنتج، وتجدول الدفعات، هذا جزء
مثلًا عندك الجهات التمويلية في هذا القطاع
تُموّلك لشراء هذه المنتجات، هذا جزء
الصادرات السعودية لهذا القطاع تموّل لك مثلًا الأيادي العاملة
أنك تسددهم
هذا جزء من البرامج الحكومية الموجودة
ممتاز، والبيع عندكم أتصوّر عن طريق الإنترنت أو في المتجر؟
طبعًا البيع عندنا في المتجر، وعندنا عن طريق الإنترنت
اللي هو كمتجر إلكتروني
والمتجر عندنا اللي هو نبيع جملة الجملة للتُجّار
وعندنا بيع اللي هو تصدير خارجي
وعندنا اللي هو العقود مع الجمعيات الخيرية وسُفَر الحرمين والأشياء هذه
إذا في الطلب الكبير هذا، ليش توجّع رأسك مع المتجر الإلكتروني وتبيع للأفراد؟
طبعًا كل واحد له مستهدَف
احنا عندنا بالهيكلة الداخلية داخل الشركة
عبارة عن هيكلتين، هيكلة التجزئة والجملة
هيكلة التجزئة فيها المتجر الإلكتروني ونقاط البيع
وهيكلة الجملة فيها المزارع والتصدير وجملة الجملة والتوزيع الخيري وغيره
التوزيع الخيري أيش سالفته؟
التوزيع الخيري مثلًا عندك عقود مع بعض الجمعات الخيرية
مثل إفطار الصائم والأشياء هذه، هذه لها تمور معينة بدرجات معينة
التصدير له نوعية تمور بدرجات معينة
والتجزئة تبيعهم من خلال المتجر الإلكتروني، وفيه برضو منافذ ثانية للبيع؟
حاليًا عندنا منفذ واحد بالرياض داخل ثمار «عقيلات»
وشغالين على التوسع في نقاط البيع
ثمار «عقيلات» تبعكم بعده؟
إي نعم
ما شاء الله، أنت دعست
الحمد لله، قطاعنا الغذائي، يارب لك الحمد والشكر
مبروك التمر هذا، ما شاء الله
كله بركة، هذه من الأشياء اللي دائمًا أقولها أن التمر فيه بركة
وعلى طاري بركة التمر، التمر كحجم سوق، حجم عالي بالنسبة للسوق
وإذا حطيناه بالأرقام، اليوم السوق السعودي فيه تقريبًا...
خلينا نعطيه أرقام، هذه خلها تفيد الناس
السعودية فيها أكثر من 30 مليون نخلة، هذا رقم
السعودية، يا طويل العمر والسلامة، بالنسبة للنخيل يمثل 12% من القطاع الزراعي
فهو يعتبر حجم مرة كبيرة
0.5% من الناتج المحلي غير النفطي، فيعتبر أيضًا رقم
7.5 مليار قيمة سوق التمر داخل السعودية
و1.2 مليار قيمة التمر خارج السعودية
هذه الأرقام تُعطي مؤشر إيجابي للي راخ يشتغل في هذا القطاع
قطاع نامي، ومدعوم من ضمن الحكومة، لأنه من ضمن بنود الرؤية
جعل السعودية المصدّر الأول للتمور
واليوم، ما شاء الله تبارك الله، السعودية تتربّع على عرش الصادرات
سابقًا وين كانت؟
كنا بمراتب متأخرة، ولكن مع البرامج الحكومية
والمركز «الوطني للنخيل والتمور والصادرات السعودية»
وبنك «الصادرات» و«وزارة الزراعة»
والجمارك وتسهيل التصدير، يا رب لك الحمد
هذه كانت كلها لأن كان في مستهدف في الرؤية؟
في مستهدف رئيسي أن تكون السعودية المصدّر الأول للتمور
والحمد لله، هذه برامج كلها إيجابية تدعم هذا القطاع
فهي مؤشر جيّد للي يبي على قولتهم يشتغل
زائد أن التمر ما يحتاجك تشتغل طول السنة هو موسمي
فأنت تشتغل 6-7 شهر
هذا اللي كنت بقوله من شوي
هذه من ضمن الأشياء اللي ما تحتاج نفس طويل
القطاع كبير، والسوق والأمور هذه كلها يمكنها قد تكون عوامل مغرية
بس أيش تسوي بالأشهر اللي ما هي بموسم؟
طبعًا في كثير من الناس
كثير من الشباب يشتغل في الموسم فقط
إما دلّال أو جلّاب يجلب التمر من المزارع، فيطلع رزقه في هذا الموسم
ويوقف باقي السنة؟
لا، عاد عنده شغل ثاني، بس يستثمرون هذه الفترة في هذا القطاع
قصدي يوقف، على شغل التمر
في ناس تجاراتهم موسمية، على سبيل المثال لما يجي التمر يشتغل تمر
لما يجي الجح يشتغل بالجح، لما يجي فيه أصناف أخرى من المنتجات
يدور المواسم المتشابكة
بالضبط
فمقسم أساسًا سنته إلى مواسم، لكن أنا أتكلم عن موسم التمر
فيه خير كبير يشغل قطاعات كثير
وأنتم أيش طريقتكم في القطاع؟
احنا بالنسبة لنا زي ما ذكرت: بالنسبة لنا عندنا تجزئة وجملة
في عندنا أشياء تُباع داخل الموسم، وفي أشياء تصدير برة
والحمد الله، عندنا مشاركات جدًّا ممتازة خارجية
وعندنا اللي هو بيع ما قبل رمضان ورمضان
بما أن الشركة عندك كل شغلها في التمر
إي
فالموظفين تقدر تشغلهم طول السنة؟
وللا في أجزاء من السنة يصيروا يشتغلون على شيء ثاني؟
في موظفين...
كم عدد الموظفين أول شيء؟
تقريبًا 15-20 موظف
حسنًا
ممتاز وفي عندك أطراف أخرى
على سبيل المثال شركة لوجستية احنا ما هي تتبعنا
احنا نشتغل مع شركتين لوجستية خارجية
شركات تسوقية احنا نشتغل طرف ثالث، شركة خارجية
ما هم موظفين من عندنا
على سبيل المثال، المخازن في المناطق الأخرى، زي الرياض وكذا
ما هي مخازننا، فالموظفين داخل المستودعات ما هم موظفيننا
فهذه كلها جزئية، موسمية على قولتهم
وأنت مهيكلها بهذه الطريقة، لأن شغلكم كموسم؟
لأنها تخدم هذا العمل التجاري
نموذج عمل هذا القطاع يعتمد على هذه الآلية
قصدي بطبيعته الموسمية
تخليك ما ودك ترتبط في أنك تصرف على الموظفين
لأنك ما تشتغل طول السنة
وللا على تشغيل طول السنة
بالضبط، نعم
بس ما تقدر تشتغل طول السنة من خلال التمر اللي تخزّنه؟
في نهاية المطاف، أنت لك استراتيجيتك في شغلك
فاحنا داخل الشركة لنا مستهدفات رقمية من حيث الإنتاج وأرقام والمبيعات
متى ما حققناهم احنا نعتبر موسمنا انتهى، قفلنا
فلك مستهدفات، فمن ضمن المستهدفات مثلًا خارجية
إذن نحتاج لمشاركات خارجية نكبّر دائرة العملاء الموجودين عندنا خارج السعودية
أنت كم يمثل عندك مبيعات التصدير من مبيعات الداخل السعودي؟
احنا الجملة بشكل عام تمثل 93% تقريبًا أو 94%
93% من مبيعاتكم برا السعودية؟
هذا بالجملة
من إجمالي مبيعاتكم؟
لا، الآن احنا كم كمبيعاتنا، الجملة يمثل عندنا 93%
دقيقة عشان أفهمها، أنت عندك تجزئة وجملة
من الجملة 93% من مبيعاته برة السعودية؟
لا، الآن مبيعاتنا جملة وتجزئة
حلو
الجملة من إنتاجنا يمثل 93% أو 94%
فتنتجون حلو، سؤالي كان عن، كم يمثل التصدير من مبيعاتكم؟
ممتاز، ثم أغلب الجملة عندنا هي تصدير
إما تصدير مباشر، احنا نصدره
أو نبيع مثلًا مشهور يصدّر في الدولة الفلانية
احنا الاحتياطي حقه، والمورّدين له
فيكون تصدير باسم مشهور، بس احنا نبيعه
فنموذج التصدير يا إنك تصدّر مباشرة أنت لعميلك اللي يكون شركات ثانية صح؟
بالضبط
أو أنك تكون تدعم تاجر يصدر للناس اللي برة
بالضبط، أنك تورّد له البضاعة اللي هو...
بس كم يمثّل من الجملة عندكم تقريبًا؟
هذه شغلتنا احنا
60% أو 70% أو 80% من مبيعات الجملة التصدير؟
احنا أغلب جملتنا تروح برة
ما تبي تقول النسبة؟
لا، أغلب جملتنا تروح برة
إي، بس الأغلب كم، 51% وللا 90%؟
لا أغلبه
تقدير بس
احنا عملائنا أساسًا اللي نبيع عليهم في الجملة أغلبهم يصدرون برة
إذا بعت لمشهور هو يبيع في مكان معين، أو أنا لي بيعات برة أساسًا
فهذه قسمتها، يمكن 80-90% من الجملة خارجية
أيش كان مدخلك على التصدير؟
مدخلي على التصدير هم العملاء اللي يجون لعندك داخل السعودية
كانوا العملاء اللي يصدرون
على سبيل المثال، مشهور كان يشتري من عندي كميات كبيرة مرة
لأنه يبيع برة، فأعطانا مؤشر إن العملاء اللي يأخذون مني جملة الجملة
أن فيها أسواق خارجية جدًّا ممتازة، وأسعار مجدية لي كمزارع
هل التمر يُباع برة بسعر أغلى من اللي يُباع هنا؟
طبعًا اللي يُباع برة جودة مختلفة عن اللي يُباع هنا
أيش الجودة اللي برة، وأيش الجودة اللي...؟
على سبيل المثال، احنا نبيع برة مركزين برة
على «السكّري الرطب» على ثلاث درجات
«السكّري الرطب» احنا ما نبيعه لا بالمتجر الإلكتروني ولا بنقاط البيع عندنا
ونادر ما نبيعه في جملة الجملة محلات داخل السعودية
ليش؟
يعتبر درجات أقل، له أسواق وشريحة مختلفة
هل لأن برة العملاء اللي في الخارج ما يميزون الجودة فتقدر تمشّي؟
قد تكون جزء، ولكن يفضلون هذا المنتج
منتج رطب، ونسبة الماء تتجاوز فيه 60% في التمرة
يفضلون مذاق التمرة هذه
بالنسبة لنا احنا هنا...
فهو المفروض التفضيل مو أنك تصرف عليهم اللي...؟
خلاص، هو يحب هذا المنتج والسعر منافس للأسواق الخارجية
اللي تنافسك في قطاع التمر، وليس في الصنف
أيش الدول الأكثر استهلاكًا للتمور من اللي تصدرون لها؟
المغرب بالنسبة لنا
المغرب تعتبر من الدول اللي تستهلك استهلاك عالي من التمور
الإمارات نصدّر لها عالي، ولكن الإمارات فيها إعادة تصدير عالي
لأنك تتكلم أنت من أعلى الدول اللي تستهلك التمر نفسه هو المغرب
أعلى الدول إجمالًا، بس المغرب الآن يستهلكون التمر...
كغذاء
مباشرة أو يصنّعون منه منتجات؟
مباشرة
ما عندهم حلويات؟
مباشرة كغذاء
حسنًا، معلومة جديدة بالنسبة لي، أيش في دولة ثانية بعد؟
الآن كتصدير الإمارات
الأعلى يعني؟
طبعًا بشكل عام الدول المسلمة تسحب منك تمور
فأنت إذا جيت تكلمت عن مثلًا الإمارات
من الدول اللي تسحب منك بشكل مرة كبير
لكن إذا كان سؤالك مختلف عن الاستهلاك
الإمارات تسحب مو بشرط أنه استهلاك داخل الإمارات
ولكن فيها تصدير جيّد عن طريق...
أبي زي المغرب، أيش في دول ثانية تستهلك بشكل كبير؟
عندك إندونوسيا وبنغلادش...
هذه من ضمن الدول اللي تسحب وعندك ماليزيا
اليوم في أسواق جديدة، وعندك مصر
عندك أسواق أيضًا جيدة تسحب، جديدة مثل روسيا
وأنت أيش كان سببك أنك تبي تصدّر مباشرة
بدال ما تكتفي بس بالتُجّار اللي يسحبون منك؟
اللي هو الفارق السعري
ما بين أنك تبيع جملة الجملة ثم يبيعوا على جملة، ويصدرّوا برة
أنا أقدر أفتح أسواق جديدة
أنت تبي الفرق هذا اللي يأخذه؟
بالضبط، وأفتح علاقات جيّدة مع تُجّار خارج السعودية
بس أساسًا شلون تصل لهم
بالضبط، جزء من أنك توصل لهم هي المعارض المدعومة
من المركز «الوطني للنخيل والتمور» و«الصادرات السعودية»
فعندهم برامج ومعارض كثيرة تشارك معهم
على أساسهم أنهم يرتبون لك مقابلات مع تُجّار محتملين في قطاعك
بس دقيقة أبي أجيك للنقطة هذه بس أيش المعارض؟
لو تذكر لي معرضين أو ثلاثة من...
على سبيل المثال، معرض «أنوقا» في ألمانيا
وللا معرض «دونق شوان» في الصين
«أنوقا» أيش يسوي؟
«أنوقا» معرض أغذية عالمي موجود في ألمانيا في مدينة كولونيا
معرض «قلفود» في الإمارات
فهي معارض أغذية بشكل عام، ما هي معارض مختصة في التمور
لا، هي معارض أغذية
ولكن من ضمن البرامج المقدمة
على سبيل المثال «الصادرات السعودية»
ترتب لك اجتماعات مع تُجّار محتملين أنهم يشتغلوا معك في هذا القطاع، بالتمر
حسنًا
إي، هذا من ضمن الجهود المبذولة على قولتهم من «الصادرات السعودية للتجارة»
الشغل يجيك جاهز المفروض، أنت بيعه بس
أنت شارك وقدم منتج كويس، ونافس سعريًّا
قدّم جودة وسعر عشان تكسب هذا الزبون اللي قدامك
إذا بغيت تشارك في معرض، أيش يطلبون منك بالضبط؟
لو بنأخذها بشكل عملي الآن، جاوا وكلّموك
وقالوا لك: أبو إبراهيم نبيك تشارك معنا في المعرض
أيش المتوقع أنك تجهز؟
على سبيل المثال، احنا اليوم، أنا ما أدري متى بتنزل هذه المقابلة
ولكن احنا في شهر تسعة، في سبتمبر 2023
احنا بسبتمبر عندنا مشاركتين، عندنا الأسبوع القادم في أمريكا
وعندنا في نهاية الشهر في الصين
أمريكا أيش هو، وين؟
أمريكا بعثة تجارية مع «الصادرات السعودية» في نيويورك
مقابلة التُجّار في هذا القطاع
حلو
بقطاع الأغذية وللا؟
إي، و«الصادرات السعودية» مرتبة لك ناس
ومقدمين لهم احنا ملفنا التمور، ومعروض على التُجّار هناك
من له رغبة في هذه المنتجات
عبدالله بيكون موجود في التاريخ وفي المكان الفلاني لمقابلتك
فـ«الصادرات السعودية» يجيبون لك واحد يبي تمر
بالضبط
مو بواحد يبي يستكشف الأغذية السعودية
بالضبط، على سبيل المثال، احنا مثلًا اجتماعنا في 12 سبتمبر
ملفنا واصل للتُجّار هناك من أول سبتمبر أو نهاية أغسطس
اللي هو ملف الشركة، وفيه تعريف عن الشركة والقطاع اللي يشتغلون فيه
والدول اللي يصدرون لها والمنتجات اللي فيها، فهذه واصلة للتُجّار
فهذا أول شي مطلوب منك، عشان تقدر تشارك في المعرض
بالضبط، اللي هو ملف الشركة
الشيء الثاني هي داعمينك في الرسوم
إذا كانت معرض بدال ما تروح تدفع رسوم معرض
وشحن بضاعة ومكلف جدًّا، تدفع رسوم رمزية
ويأخذون لك ركن، ويشحنون لك بضاعتك للدولة
حتى الشحن عليهم بعد؟
حتى الشحن يقدمونه لك
إذا كنا عمليًّا يقدمون لك 150 كيلو شحن مجاني على حسابهم
ما لك عذر أبد أجل
أبدًا، لا صراحة كبرامج للأمانة جدًّا ممتازة
الصادرات أشوف عندهم في المعارض حتى أذكر في «جيتكس»
شفتهم يكون عندهم يأخذون ركن كبير
المعارض عندك «الصادرات السعودية» و«المركز الوطني للنخيل والتمور»
وعندك مدن
المركز الوطني لأيش؟
«للنخيل والتمور»
حلو
نعم
وكلهم يدعمونكم بنفس الطريقة؟
وهذول كل واحد، هذول عندهم معرض وهذول عندهم معرض
صراحةً البرامج للأمانة كثيرة، تحتاج منك بس تتحرك وتبادر
فأنت توفر الملف حق الشركة والبضاعة اللي بتروح تبيعها هناك
وفي شيء ثاني برضو تحتاجه للمشاركة في المعرض
سيرة موجزة، وتقدم كتيّبات وأشياء زي كذا وعينات
الطباعة عليك بعد؟
لا أنت... باقي يبيعون عنك
ما أدري، خلاص سووا كل شيء
لا والله، كثّر الله خيرهم، صراحةً أنك توصل البلدان
على سبيل المثال، الجدول عندنا
تكلمنا عن أمريكا والصين وألمانيا، وفي الإمارات ومصر وأربيل بالعراق
في عدة دول، لما تدخل على «الصادرات السعودية»
وللا «المركز الوطني للنخيل والتمور»
وتحط المعارض الخارجية
ما شاء الله، تبارك الله، جدول السنة مُكتمل
موقعهم؟
موقعهم الرسمي
بس هذه متوفرة لأي أحد، وللا في معايير معينة عشان...؟
تسجل عندهم، قطاعك أيًّا كان مثلًا غذائي تمور فتسجل معهم غذائي تمور
غذائي آخر، لأن الصادرات ما هي بس صادرات تمور
هذه صادرات بشكل عام، صادرات غير نفطية
فأنت عندك أي منتج قابل للتصدير؟
أي منتج سعودي، على سبيل المثال، الصادرات السعودية عندها برنامج
اسمه صُنِعَ في السعودية
صُنِعَ في السعودية هذا يشارك على سبيل المثال
في معرض «قلفود» في دبي بمعرض ضخم جدًّا
هذا أي منتج يُصنّع في السعودية، ما هو شرط تمر
شفته، ورحت له المرة الماضية
عظيم جدًّا
منتجات كثير سعودية
وأنت كمشارك كلما عليك أنك تلتزم في ركنك
وتقدم منتجاتك، وهم منسقين لك اجتماعات مع تُجّار محتملين لك
أيش تبي أكثر؟
بس أيش الآن؟ عشان ما نخلي الشخص يعتقد الموضوع سهل جدًّا
ومتاح لكل أحد
لو أنت جيت وفي خمسين تاجر تمر جاء، يختارون مَن؟
طبعًا هنا يبقى قوتك التصديرية
قوة العلامة التجارية حقك والبنية التحتية من ملف شركة وهيكلة
أنا أتكلم مثلًا عن شغلنا من مزارع وأشياء زي كذا تجي تدريجيّة
بس في أشياء متاحة مثلًا قد تكون سهلة
اللي هي يسوون اجتماعات عبر الإنترنت
مثل هذه المعارض بس تكون عبر الإنترنت
تقدر تحضرها، وورش عمل عبر الإنترنت
فهذه يمكن التُجّار الأصغر يقدرون...
هذه إذا كنت ما لك تجربة، تقدر تبدأ فيها
ثم تتعرف على التُجّار، وتأخذ التفاصيل
كيف ممكن أشارك في هذه المعارض؟
ثم تدخل بالتفاصيل بعدين
والله بتشارك في هذا المعرض، وتحتاج مثلًا إلى شهادات زراعية
تحتاج إلى شهادات منشأ وشهادات صحية، بعض التفاصيل هذه
ولكن هي تتطور مع الوقت
لكن أتكلم اليوم، هل في برامج؟ نعم
هل هي تستحق؟ بصراحة أكثر من أنها تستحق
حجم التصدير حقكم اليوم؟ إذا تبغى تقول
اليوم، ولله الحمد، نصدّر بشكل كبير، أطنان كبيرة جدًّا
وين تتوقع موقعكم من بين مصدرين التمور؟
وقد أقول من أعلى خمسة مصدرين
هل أنتم كثير أصلًا اللي تصدرون التمور وللا؟
نعم، اليوم من الصادرات سعودية قيمة الصادرات خارج السعودية 1.2 مليار
لا قصدي اللي يصدرون تمر تحديدًا؟
إي، في كمية ما هي بسيطة
حجم الصادرات كأطنان أكثر من 320 ألف طن
تمر؟
تمر إي، وفي نمو متزايد من حيث الكمية والسعر، متوسط الكيلو
فيه تحدي، عشان برضو أنا دايمًا
أحب أتجنب السواليف اللي كذا طالعة كأنها سهلة وسلسة جدًّا بزيادة
أيش التحديات الموجودة في التصدير؟
فهم الأسواق والمنتج المناسب لأي بلد
فكل بلد له صنف وجودة منتج وسعر معين
فهم هذه الأسواق يعطيك تسهيل وصول منتجك للجهة الصحيحة بشكله صحيح
ولكن أنا أقول: اليوم المعارض اللي ما تقدر تشارك فيها
على الأقل زُرها أنت شخصيًّا، وشوف الناس كيف تشارك؟
ناظر مَن هم الزبائن اللي يجون، وكيف يقدمون المنتجات حقتهم؟
وأيش المنتجات اللي يقدمونها؟
لأن بعض العلامات التجارية اللي لها مشاركات كثيرة
ولها سنوات تشارك برة، مختصرة عليك دارسه لك السوق
فالمنتج اللي على الطاولة ويعرضه، هو المنتج المطلوب في هذا البلد
من ناحية جودة وسعر؟
كل شيء
كلما تحتاج له تزورهم كأنك تاجر، كأنك عميل عندهم
تأخذ فكرة معينة، وطبقها عندك، هذه كذا بطريقة سهلة جدًّا
أنت تقول: أنت مريت على «صُنِع في السعودية» في الإمارات
وأنت زائر، خلاص تدري أن والله اللي يصدرون فلان وفلان
هؤلاء دائمًا من المشاركين اللي تشوفهم بالمعارض
والمنتجات اللي يصدرونها هناك
هذا المنتج والجودة الفلانية، وبمتوسط هذه الأسعار
إذن خلاص أنت اختصرت 50-60-70% من المعلومات اللي تحتاجها للمشاركة
أنا متأكد أنكم طحتوا في مشاكل في بداية التصدير
كل أحد يمر بمشاكل
هذه بس ودي نتكلم شوية، مثلما تكلمنا عن المزايا
اليوم جزء، على سبيل المثال من اللي قد تطيح فيها
واليوم البرامج الجديدة، لأن احنا سنة عن سنة تجينا برامج
على سبيل المثال، تحصل زبون ممتاز في بلد معين
وممتاز وصلت لزبون، ويبغى عشرة طن، في ثقة البيع
أن كيف أبيع عليه وأشحن له المنتج، وأنا ما استلمت فلوسي؟
وهو يقول لك: كيف أنا أعطيك فلوسي، وأنا ما استلمت منتجي؟
قد يكون منتجي اللي أنا شاريه ما يجيني بالشكل اللي أبيه
فـ«الصادرات السعودية» هنا قدمت حل ومنتج اسمه التأمين
التأمين أن تأمّن للطرفين استلام المبلغ واستلام البضاعة
تسلّم هذا مبلغ وتسلّم هذا بضاعته، تضمن للطرفين
هذا منتج طبعًا ما كان موجود سابقًا
سهّل عليك عملية البيع، فأنا مشهور وعايش مثلًا في بريطانيا وأبي أبيع عليه
ما أحتاج أني أعرف مشهور، وللا أني أضمنه
بيني وبينه «الصادرات السعودية»
الصادرات تربط مع مشهور، ومعنا بالشركة
وتضمن لمشهور منتجه يوصل كما هو، وتضمن لي أنا مبلغي يوصلني كما هو
كلما أسألك عن تحدي، تطلع لي ميزة جديدة
لأن صراحة البرامج، ماشاء الله تبارك الله، متجددة وتحل المشاكل
وهذه البرامج ما تجي إلا من ورش عمل بناءً على المشاكل السابقة
البرامج بلا شك جدًّا ممتازة
لكن أنا أقصد أن هذا ما كانت موجود، فكانت مشكلة
أعطني مشكلة ثانية ما حُلّت للحين؟ اللي فعلًا الواحد...
التسويق الخارجي ما زال يحتاج إلى شغل أكبر
ولكن ما زالت «الصادرات السعودية» قاعدة تشتغل عليها
ليش تحتاج تسويق خارجي وأنت «الصادرات السعودية» تسوّق لك؟
لا بس لسه أنت تحتاج إلى تصدير أكبر لهذا المنتج
وتعريف هذا المنتج في أماكن كثير
الصادرات اليوم السعودية احنا شغالين معهم في برامج كثيرة
ما زالت إلى الآن ما طلعت
من ضمنها إنهم يشيلون عنك التسويق برة، ويتبنونك برة
أو يدعمونك بنسبة كبيرة من ميزانية التسويق خارج السعودية
أيش ممكن تتوقع منهم غير أنهم يربطونك مع التُجّار؟
أيش التسويق اللي تتوقعه منهم؟
لأنك في النهاية تبيع لتُجّار جملة ثانيين
بالضبط، ولكن دخول الأسواق وتسويقها
الحملات اللي تسويها، الحين وأنت داخل السعودية
تبيع داخل متجر إلكتروني تسوي حملة سواءً رقيمًّا أو مع مشاهير
أو إعلانات أوفلاين أو أيًّا كان، هذه لها ميزانية
اليوم الصادرات عندها برامج، إن شاء الله، سترى النور قريبًا
تدعمك في هذا الشيء حتى خارج السعودية
عشان تصل لتُجّار إضافيين وللا للأفراد؟
سواءً تُجّار أو أفراد
عندكم خطة أن تبيعون للأفراد برة؟
عندنا خطة أن نوصل لأي سوق يطلب التمر
هذا اللي يخلينا أننا نشارك في أكبر
على قولتهم: معارض ممكنة بحيث أننا نساهم في رفع الصادرات
وهو أحد المستهدفات، وبالنسبة لنا تكبّر لنا المزارع
احنا عندنا مستهدفات أخرى مثلًا استحواذ على عدد مزارع معينة
وعدد نخيل معين، نسبة النمو عندنا سنوية
أنا عشان أكبر بالمزارع والنخيل، أحتاج أني أبيع الإنتاج اللي قاعد يطلع إياه
وعلشان أبيع أفتح أسواق جديدة، فأكبّر دائرة العملاء الموجودة عندنا
الإنتاج كبير لدرجة أنه يفيض عليك اليوم؟
بالضبط، أنت شلون تقسم الإنتاج ما بين التجزئة وما بين...؟
التجزئة بالنسبة لي علامة تجارية، وليس مصدر دخل رئيسي
ويحافظ لي على...
ترويج للهوية فقط
وأيضًا الاستثمار في البرامج التقنية مثلًا أداة تقنية جديدة
أداة دفع جديدة وخدمة لوجستية جديد
كل هذا تستكشفه عن طريق الإنترنت، والتجارة الإلكترونية بشكل عام
وأنك تكون متواجد واسمك متواجد
بس، كم نسبة اللي يروح للتجزئة، واللي يروح للجملة؟
التجزئة بالنسبة لنا احنا زي ما قلنا ما يتجاوز تقريبًا 6% من إنتاجنا
ففعليًّا شغلك كله جملة؟
جملة نعم
جزء بسيط فقط...؟
جزء بسيط مركز عليه، لأن بالنهاية الشركات لها قيَم سوقية
قد بعدين تفكر أنك تطرح أو يجيك استحواذ
جزء من التقييم هو العلامة التجارية الموجودة عندك اللي أنت أسستها
واللي جزء كبير من هذه العلامة التجارية يجي من التجزئة
سواءً تجارة إلكترونية أو نقاط بيع
واليوم أنت بس تصدّر وتبيع بالتجزئة للسعودية
بس ما تبيع تجزئة في أسواق ثانية؟
ما عندي نقاط بيع ثانية إلا في الرياض في ثمار العقيلات حاليًّا
وناوي أنك يصير عندك نقاط بيع خارج السعودية؟
بإذن الله، سواءً نفتح محلات فروع مستقلة بالعلامة التجارية نفسها
أو نتوسع في السوق يعني نقاط نأخذهن أو عن طريق التطبيقات
تعتقد أنه ممكن تضبط بنفس النموذج اللي احنا نعمل فيه في سوق السعودية؟
اللي هو؟
نقاط بيع التجزئة
إي، تضبط ليش لا؟
خلال زياراتنا الماضية لبعض الدول
في أرفف مخصصة للتمور سواءً تمور السعودية وللا غيرها
بس مثلًا، اللي في المغرب وللا في الصين
وللا أيًّا كان العملاء اللي يشترون التمور المصدرة
إذا جاوا يشترون بالتجزئة، هل هم يأخذونه مثلًا تاجر الجملة اللي هناك
أو تاجر التجزئة اللي برة
هل هو يأخذه ويحطه في تغليف لطيف، ويضبطه ويبيعه لهم
وللا كراتين زي وضعنا؟
لا، مو كراتين
بالنسبة للأرفف، غالبًا أنت تدرس ثقافة السوق، هذا جزء ثاني
أنت اليوم من الأشياء اللي توّ كنت أتكلم عنها
الميزانيات والتسويق اللي تحتاجها برة
جزء من هذا التسويق ليس بيعي هو تثقيفي
فالتثقيف، تثقف الناس وتفهم وتدرس
توقّع مع شركة، وتدرس لك السوق
الناس أيش يبون ويستهلكون؟
250 أو 200 أو 100 قرام أو بالحبات؟
هم أصلًا كيف يشوفون التمر؟
ربع كيلو، بالضبط
هل هو ديني، أتصور كذا أو صحّي؟
بس تدخل على قطاعات أخرى مثلًا الرياضية فصحّي
تدخل على الأطفال صحّي، وتدخل على مثلًا...
الرياضية أيش فيه؟
إي كبروتين، الرياضيين أتكلم عن القطاع الرياضي
بروتين نسبة قليلة؟
بالعكس التمور...
هو يعتبر صحي
صحي بالضبط إي
فأنا أتكلم عن الصحيين سواءً رياضيين أو أطفال أو كمنتج صحي
فيه كامل القيم الغذائية اللي يحتاجها الجسم
فهذا أنت عشان توصله
ما تقدر تجي تقول: يا مشهور اشتر من عندي منتج، هذا أيش هو؟
إذن تحتاج إلى صرف ميزانية توعوية
وتوصل للناس التوعية الموجودة عن هذا المنتج
بس التوقعات للمنتج مختلفة؟
أكيد
طريقة العرض حتى مختلفة
بالضبط، أنت ممكن، وهذا افتراض من رأسي، إذا بكون صحيح وللا لا
ممكن مثلًا تروح تبيع عليهم في أمريكا تمر
كل حبة مغلفّة تبيع عليهم ثلاث حبات بس
بالضبط، لكن أنت كيف تحددد إنها ثلاث حبات؟
حلوى الصحراء
بالضبط 250 قرام أو أيًّا كان، دراستك للسوق هذا جزء مهم مرة
فهم السوق الموجود عندك، فأنت بتسوي اختبارات
والاختبارات هذه مُكلِفة، لها فلوس
تجارب؟
إي، تجرّب
في شركات تساعدك تسوي تجارب برة للمنتجات؟
هذه الشركات اللي بعض الجهات الحكومية أنك تقدمها
وفي عملية التصدير
هل في أي تصنيف لجودة التمر، وللا زي المنتجات الثانية؟
هي مثلها مثل أي...
وللا المزارع عندهم؟
عرض وطلب، بس أنا أشوف التمور السعودية
تعتبر من المنتجات عالية الجودة، وتنافس بسعرها
إي، بس هل في تصنيف رسمي؟
أنت اللي حين تتكلم عن المزارع، نوعًا ما في تقارب بين المعايير حقتهم
بس الآن تجي تتكلم ما بين الدولة ودولة
إي، ما في تصنيف مباشر
ما في تمر فئة ألف؟
لا
مع أن وزارة الزراعة تشتغل على هذا القطاع
ولكن في نهاية المطاف أنت اليوم كتاجر
تصنيفك اللي يحدده هو العميل حقك تاجر الجملة
لما يجي يشتري من عندك يقول: هذا مناسب لزبائني ودولتي وكذا
فيختار على عينه وعلى معرفته
ما في منتجات ثانية غير التمر فيها تصنيفات؟
غير التمر؟
إي
عندك عجينة التمر، على سبيل المثال
معجون التمر، بعض المصانع يستخدمونه بالحلويات
فيقول: والله أبي شيء ليّن ولونه أصفر، ممتاز
أبي شيء ما ينشف لما أحطه مثلًا في الحلويات والمعمول أو غيره
فهذه لها أنواع من التمور هي اللي تُباع لهذا الصنف
ما تتوقع بتستفيد لو كان في تصنيف رسمي سواءً في التصدير أو محليًّا؟
في نهاية المطاف منتج غذائي، ما تقدر تصنفه، ليش ما سويت؟
لو جاءت هبّة مطر أو هب ريح حار، يُسمّى تمر صفيق
بيستمر الموضوع على... يقيسونه الأشخاص
يجيك واحد يقول له: لا، أنا تمري فاخر
هو زي ما قلت لك: في معايير معينة، والتاجر يعرفها من التجربة
والله حجم الحبة ولونها
وهذه النقطة أن أنت الحين ممكن اللي تشوفه فاخر
في واحد ثاني يشوفه درجة أولى صح؟
بالضبط
بس ما تقدر تحكم هذا المنتج، أنه مو صناعي
المنتج هذا زراعي تحكمه ظروف الأجواء
فلا بُد يكون في مساحة للـ...؟
إي، فخلّها عايمة
ما كانت عائق لكم؟
أبدًا
أن واحد يحاول يمرر المنتجات...؟
لا، ما دامك تفهم أنت السوق اللي قدامك
وأنت عارف تحدد له المنتج اللي هو يبيه
ليش ما أصدّر أنا مثلًا فاخر؟ أدري أن ما راح يمشي أبد
لا سعرًا ولا قبول عند الناس هناك برة، أنا وجدت هذا السوق...
ليش؟ يقولون: هذا شكله...
لأن نسبة الألياف عالية فغالبًا اللي ما يتعود على التمر ما يقبله
بينما عندنا «المفتّل» هنا أغلى بكثير من الرطب
بس الرطب نسبة المياه فيه عالية والألياف فيه أقل، مقبول أكثر
غريبة، أيش علاقة الألياف في الموضوع؟
الألياف تأكل ناشفة التمرة، ما تحس مياهها ولا سكر
هم يأخذونها أكثر أقرب للحلى؟
إي، أقرب للحلى
مو بس احنا نشوف التمر؟
احنا لا لنا تصنيف آخر كمستهلكين نفهم في هذا المنتج
من تعتبره منافسك اليوم أو المنافسين في السوق؟
السوق فيه منافسين
بس ما في ناس معروفين ممكن أنك...؟
إلا في ناس، السوق مفتوحة
في ناس زيكم تجزئة وجملة وكذا شغل؟
إي في ناس زيكم تجزئة وجملة، والسوق مفتوح للجميع وهذا جميل
نرجع لنقطة من يريد أن يدخل في هذا القطاع
ميزة هذا القطاع أيضًا ما تحتاج له في كثير من الأحيان إلى رؤوس أموال كبيرة
لما تروح لمزارعين أو تُجّار جملة
قد يدعمونك زي ما أنا بدأت في سالفة على التصريف
بس هذه برضو بنفس الوقت مشكلة
لأنه معناته في ناس داخلين السوق هذا، لأن ما في عائق للدخول
الله يبارك لهم، بالعكس والسوق مفتوح للجميع، ويسع الجميع
بس إذا أنا و70 ألف واحد غيري قادر أنه يجي، ويأخذ التمر هذا
أو يسوي نفس الطريقة حقك
معناته احتمالية أني أحقق مبيعات جيدة بتكون قليلة
مقارنة بسوق ثاني مثلًا صعب الدخول فيه
السوق سهلٍ صعب، سهل أنك تدخل فيه، وصعب تستمر فيه
سهل الدخول فيه لحكم من يورّد لك الكثير
وصعب أن تستمر فيه لهوامش الربح القليلة
اللي تحتاج إلى عكفة رجل، وصبر طويل حتى تبني روحك
أنت ذكرت 30% أو 40% فأبي توضح الآن أيش...؟
صوافيك حسب تكاليفك
على مستوى المنتج بس في التكاليف الثانية
الصوافي تتفاوت من واحد لواحد
وزائد أنه موسمي، فكثير من الناس يبي يدخل ويترزق الله في وقت الموسم
وما بعد الموسم؟
ممتاز، زائد أن التمر زي ما قلنا...
أيش التكاليف اللي تأكل من هامش الربح حقك؟
اليوم بالنسبة لنا، التكاليف التشغيلية
اللي هي جزء منها الأيادي العاملة بشكل مرة كبير
إيجارات المستودعات الموجودة عندنا
جزء كبير منها أيضًا في الخدمات اللوجستية
بالنسبة أن التسويق الموجود عندنا
التوصيل أو الخدمات اللوجستية، أيش المشكلة فيها؟
التكلفة نصرف عليها، نجي مثلًا في التجارة الإلكترونية المتجر
ونقدم احنا كثير من العروض الموجودة عندنا شامل التوصيل
شامل التوصيل يعني أنا أدفعه
والمبرد سعره أعلى بكثير من الجاف
الجاف أقل، يعني متوسط أسعار، لكن المبرد والتمر اللي يحتاج للمبرد
غالي علينا احنا وعلى الزبون
بالنسبة للشركات المقدمين لخدمة التوصيل المبرد
فأنت حتى في النقل من المزارع للمستودعات
أو المستودعات للـ، أنا ما أدري تطلع مباشرة من المستودعات؟
أتكلم عن التجزئة أنا الحين
إي، فقصدي أنا إجمالًا في عملياتكم بشكل عام كلها نقل مبرد؟
إي
حتى اللي من المزارع؟
المزارع لا، اللي وقتها من المزارع اللي هذا
لا، هذه أساسًا طازجة من المزارع إلى السوق
ما يحتاج أنه يكون مبرد أساسًا
فما يصير مبرد إلا وقت التخزين؟
وقت التخزين، التمر إذا دخل للتجميد
لما يطلع يكون أعلى حساسية بس ما دامه طازج جديد، ما يتأثر، ويتحمل
يتحمل فترة أطول
مجرد ما تبرده خلاص
لأنه لا طلع بيكون فيه رطوبة، لأنه ماسك تجميد
ولما يفك هذا التجميد، ويصير ماء
لما يرجع يمسك مرة ثانية هنا يأثر رطوبة على التمر
مثلًا فالتمرة صفرة بتصير حمرة أو سمرة نسبةً للرطوبة الموجودة راح تأثر عليه
فيحتاج أنك...
تحافظ عليه بشكل مرة جيّد سواءً بالتخزين أو بالنقل للمستهلكين
عندك تكاليف تخزين ونقل؟
وتكاليف التسويق
إي، أكيد بما أن في ناس يبيعون تمر فتكاليف التسويق أعلى
بالضبط، فهذه من التكاليف اللي هي عالية
زي ما قلت لك: منتج يحتاج إلى شخص تثق فيه عشان تشتري منه
وعشان تصل إلى هذه المرحلة تصرف واجد
جوي الصعوبات هذه، احنا نتكلم وإلى هذه النقاط في الحلقة
نتكلم عن أيش كثر الموضوع سهل
فودي نركز على هذه النقطة عشان يعرفوا...
أنا ذكرت دخول سهل، والاستمرارية صعبة
والتكاليف عالية؟
بحكم الصعوبات اللي ذكرناها
تحقيق الربحية هو يمكن اللي حدكم أنكم تأخذون مزارع
هذه ترجع إلى استراتيجيتك وقوتك وحجمك
يعتمد عليه أخذ مزارع أو جاهز أو من السوق مباشرة
حسب استراتيجيتك
طيب وين رايحين مستقبلًا، وين توجهكم؟
اليوم في «بالما»...
غير مسألة إنك، تزيد مبيعاتك طبعًا، من الأشياء اللي تسويها اليوم
اليوم في «بالما» عندنا عدة مستهدفات داخلية داخل الشركة
واحدة منها هي الاستحواذ على أكبر عدد مزارع ممكنة
للثلاث نقاط اللي ذكرناهم، رفع جودة المنتج وإنتاجية وضبط التكاليف
فهذه المزارع الموجودة عندنا
فتح أسواق جديدة وتعريف تحديدًا «السكّري» في بلدان جديدة
بالنسبة لنا سوق الصين يُعتبر جديد، ومشاركتنا هذا الشهر
والشهر القادم، إن شاء الله، مشاركة ثانية في أكتوبر
تُعتبر جديدة علينا
ولكن الصين فيها 200 مليون مسلم، والسوق ضخم جدًّا
أنت لو تأخذ منه 1% أنت فتحت سوق، وباب كبير فيه
بس في أساسًا سوق كبير، وإقبال كبيرة على التمر هناك؟
طبيعي جدًّا أن هؤلاء كلهم يصومون في رمضان المفترض
فهؤلاء إذا وصل لهم التمر، يفطرون على التمر
أخاف تصدر لهم التمر ويقلدونه بعدين
والله...
هم داخلين بالأنسجة عاد
لكن هذه قد تكون من التحديات الموجودة
ممكن يشوف زين هذا، يروح ينسخه
بالضبط، لكن هذا سوق كبير، على سبيل المثال
الهند سوق ضخم جدًّا، وشفنا اليوم، ما شاء الله تبارك الله
الهند تنافس عدد سكان الصين
ودخلتوا الضاهر على منتجات ثانية غير التمر صح؟
عندنا منتجات ثانية
الزعفران...؟
إي بس احنا تركيزنا الفعلي لما تجي تراجع أوراقك
الرهان على هذا التمر
بس وراك دخلت على منتجات ثانية؟
التكبير، هذا غالبًا بالتجزئة والتجارة الإلكترونية بشكل عام
عشان الزبون لما يدخل عندك يحصل عندك منتجات أخرى، يكبّر السلة
لما يجي يدفع على شحن على هذا المنتج
إذن يستحق أني أخذ منتج واحد واثنين وثلاثة
فأنت تختار الأشياء اللي حول التمر
بالضبط، وما زلنا في التطوير
احنا نفكر أن كل فترة ننزل منتج
ولكن هذا لقطع التجزئة تحديدًا تجارة إلكترونية
أما الجملة والتصدير احنا مركزين بشكل مرة كبير
لأنها هي سلسلة إمداد مكملة لبعض
أنا اليوم عشان أكبر في مزارعي وعدد نخيلي وغراسي السنوي
إذن أحتاج أبيعك أكبر
وإذا أحتاج بيع أكبر، أحتاج إلى فتح أسواق جديدة
وتعريف هذا المنتج في هذه الأسواق
والتجزئة جابوا لك عملاء للجملة؟
التجزئة تجيب، لأنك أساسًا تضخ فيها ميزانية تسوقية
إلا ما تلقى فيها عملاء، وغالبًا عملاء الجملة يكونون داخل السعودية
ما يكونوا بالخارج، بحكم أن حملاتك التسوقية داخل السعودية
استفدت على فكرة...
والفنادق مثلًا، توريد فنادق
تكون على سبيل المثال، عقود مع شركات، وهدايا
أعتقد برضو ممكن تستفيد من الحراك الرياضي اللي صار الحين مع السياحة اللي جاءت
هذه أيضًا باب كبير جدًّا اليوم الرياضة والسياحة والثقافة أيضًا جزء منها
اللي هو المنتج السعودي سواءً التمر أو القهوة السعودية وغيرها
أنك تقدمها بقوالب معينة، هذه من ضمن دراسة السوق
تقدم بقوالب معينة تتوافق مع هذا التوجه
و2024 جايتنا مع الأجانب اللي راح يجون مع الشركات
إلا ما يحتاجون يتثقفون، تقدم لهم المنتج أنت
فأنت وجودك، السوق يحتاج إلى دراسة وتطوير مستمر
حلو، قدموا تمر خاص بـ«رونالدو» اسمه ألما
اسمه؟
الكلمة حقته دائمًا يقول: «كالما»
إي يستاهل
فألما وكالما
إي، يستاهل
أعطيكم فكرة تسويقية
بالعكس أبركها من ساعة، نتشرف
الله يعطيك العافية أبو إبراهيم
الله يعافيك يا بعد عيني
سعدت جدًّا بلقائك
أثريتنا بشكل كبير في يمكن منتج جميعنا نستهلكه، بس ما نعرف تفاصيله
على الأقل أنا كشخص ما أعرف تفاصيل كثيرة فيه
أعرف التمر «السكّري» اللي يوصلني إلى البيت، لكن...
لا، شوي شوي نثقفك فيه
إي، الله يعطيك العافية
ونعطيك حصة
بس الأنواع وهذا ما يخفيك، صراحة أنا ماني بداخل بتفاصيل كثيرة فيها
والسوق حقه برضو أنت وضحت لناس كثير من اللي مستبسطينه وماخذينه
لا يا ابن خُذ الكراتين وبيعها وخلاص
فأنت وضحت على الأقل جزء من الجانب هذا
الحمد لله، إن شاء الله، وصلّنا رسالة جيدة
جدًّا
ونرجع نقول: التمر فيه بركة، والله يبارك للي يشتغل فيه
واللي يبي يدخل، الله يحييه
عاد ما جبت لنا شيء اليوم، بس يلا
ابشر
كثّر خيرك، يعطيك العافية أبو إبراهيم
يا هلا، الله يسعدك ويبارك بعمرك، ويبيض وجهك
شكرًا لكم على الاستضافة
شكرًا لكم
وشكرًا لعبد الملك آل سعيد في إنتاج المحتوى
في التحرير: مرام ضبيبان
في إدارة التصوير: ياسر بن غانم
في الإضاءة: عبدالمجيد عمر
في الهندسة الصوتية: عبدالعزيز المزي
في الإخراج الفني: مجد الملّي، ومساعده: وسيم معين
وفي الإنتاج التنفيذي: غيداء التميمي
هذا بودكاست سوالف بزنس، أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع